ريو دي جانيرو مدينة رائعة
لكنك لست دائمًا مدينة
رائع
[موسيقى]
أنت لست مارسيلو موديستو
نحن في مجتمع Cidade de Deus
الكاراتيه وفي المكان الذي أقوم بتدريس أ
مجموعة الأطفال
الفيلم مدينة الله الذي صوره
جزء من واقع العنف
جريمة نعيشها
كل يوم رأيت الناس يتم إطلاق النار عليهم
مثل 50 مترًا، هذا أمر سريالي
وهذا يعني أننا في نهاية المطاف نعتقد أن هذا هو
العمل الذي أقوم به هنا طبيعي
في النواة الاجتماعية الفضائية في كويلومبو
العمل في عكس اتجاه العدو هناك
العدو هناك
أنت متعبة صوفيا لقد بدأت المشروع
لعبة الجولف في Cidade de Deus اللعب بها
طفلاي وخمسة أطفال آخرين
بدأت بتعليمهم القواعد و
اتضح أنها مزحة
أصبح مشروعا خطيرا
أقول له أنهم ليسوا منهم
لا يوجد أعداء هنا
يتدربون معًا
الالتزام بالمواعيد لا يعني احترام واحد فقط
الزميل هنا لا يحترم الأب
احترام الأم احترام المعلم
لذا أعطيه فكرة الانضباط، أليس كذلك؟
الاحترام قبل كل شيء
حاليا نتدرب معهم مرتين
مرات في الأسبوع في مركزي الصغير هناك
[موسيقى]
كل 15 يوما نأخذ هذه
الأطفال في ملعب الجولف الأولمبي
ملعب
[موسيقى]
فإذا أصبح كل واحد من هؤلاء الأطفال
مواطن محترم هذا هو حالنا
فكرة لماذا اسم لدينا
المشروع هو مصنع للأبطال هنا
الناس نريد تحويل الأبطال
من الحياة
[موسيقى]